foreign
for Christmas is very popular now in
Japan and so I was walking home and I
stole KFC inside of the big station
nearby and I saw the line and I was
wondering like like what's happening and
I realized that there they were you know
lined up for Kentucky for Christmas and
that's when I learned that oh it's the
thing KFC Japan started in 1970. the
first store manager is Takeshi or kawara
so in 1974 they started the promotion
like the slogan Kentucky for Christmas
or Kentucky Christmas which I am
familiar with I grew up here in that
from the TV and so forth and in 1985
according to their website they began
the Christmas symbol party Barrel I I
think the idea is that if you get one
barrel then the table will be set for
Christmas the sales of KFC dream
Christmas week the average seems to be
about 7 billion yen so that's probably a
52 million dollars in the US when I
think of KFC I often picture the Colonel
Sanders uh statue that's pretty much
everywhere in Japan in areas like in and
outside we're talking like Tokyo area
there are about
307 restaurants of KSC and other places
there are
865. there are only 47 prefectures in
Japan so that's a lot of a KFC as for
the religious background in Japan I saw
the data from Agency for cultural
Affairs it's the whole 2020 data
according to them
48 Shinto 46 percent Buddhism Christians
are only 1.1 percent for the Christian
number is very low but but still like we
celebrate Christmas also in addition to
that of course we have our uh
traditional Japanese stuff to celebrate
too so I guess that we're just happy
people celebrating everything that we
can